i actually want to
understand the world i live in as best i
can because
i actually hold that life is meaningful
and i hold that my life could be
meaningful which means that my choices
can be meaningful
and so i want them to be informed as
well as they can be
what i think people really liked about
our first conversation
was that we brought some of your work
down to an
individual level so a friend referred to
it as creating a narrative of resonance
and given that i thought it would be
nice to start by looking at something
that you talk about a lot which is sense
making
but from the level of the actor so
how do you define a sense-making agent
well i don't know what
background the other people listening to
your show will have on the general topic
when
you're mentioning individual agents i
think you mean individual humans
obviously an organization can act like
an agent
um act like a a unit of agency uh but i
think you mean
uh individuals seeking to make sense of
the world they live in
better we oftentimes talk about sense
making at a societal level meaning
uh and currently it comes up a lot like
why do we have such a hard time coming
to clear understanding about what the
nature of climate change is or what the
nature of
covet viral origins or vaccines or
whatever
systemic racism or how we should deal
with nuclear disarmament or
why does it seem like there are such
radically divergent views meaning the
way that we're sensing the world is
leading to very different senses of the
world
which of course leads to very different
senses of what should happen
which makes it very hard to coordinate
which makes it very easy to have
conflict and so when we're talking about
sense making we're usually talking about
it in the context of shared sense making
as a prerequisite for shared choice
making
i.e governance sense makings on the only
prerequisite
when we talk about governance and by
governance i don't mean government which
is a
maybe a specific um establishment that
has
a rule of law and monopoly of violence
but governance meaning some process by
which
a bunch of people who want different
things and see the world differently
come to coordinate force in some
effective
positive productive ways
so we're talking about how do we get
people to have some kind of coherence or
coordination between the choices they
make
such that it isn't making choices that
we would think of as crime or something
that really messes up each other's
choice making capacity
and where we need to coordinate on
choices like we're not going to all make
our own roads and things like that that
we're able to coordinate effectively
regarding
shared resources shared infrastructure
shared choices
it happens to be that lots of humans who
don't know each other
and have experienced the world
differently and feel different things
and want different things coordinating
on what the right choices is a tricky
thing right because they have a
different sense of
what is and what they want and what
should be so
this is why for most of human history
the number of people that would
coordinate was small
tribes were small they classically
stayed beyond you know smaller than the
dunbar number give or take 150 ish
where there were no strangers everybody
that you were coordinating with you'd
known your whole life they had known you
your whole life
everybody had the same shared basis of
experience
and everybody could be in a single
conversation around a campfire
and so the ability to coordinate we
could coordinate sense making because we
were sensing the same stuff we live in
the same place right we weren't even
reading different books we weren't even
watching different tv shows like we were
nobody had been we weren't speaking
different languages we were exposed to
the same stuff
and so you could also fact check anybody
just by
looking there right by just having such
a shared basis
and it was pretty easy to unify values
because
the culture that had conditioned them
was the same culture um
so there might be little differences of
waiting and so then the ability to
you know unify choice making if we have
shared values and we have shared sense
of the world so both what we think is
and what we want to be
it's not that hard um once we started to
get to larger scales where
now i've got to maybe make compromises
for strangers
i've got you know we're going to have
some coordination
with people who i don't have any shared
sense of
real fealty with whatever that becomes a
different topic and where they really do
see the world differently
and so this is where mostly the order
came through some kind of imposition or
oppression or top-down force which is
why it was largely
empires okay and then that still meant a
number of people smaller than dunbar
that would equal the king and a council
making the decisions and imposing it by
rule of law enforcement on everybody
right
so shared sense making didn't matter
because people didn't really have
meaningful choices they were going to do
the thing that they were going to do
within that context
so the idea of something like democracy
or a republic or an open society
where some humongous number of people
who don't know each other who don't have
the same experiences are all going to
not just do totally different stuff that
creates chaos
but also not need somebody to kind of
rule they're going to find order that
isn't imposed it's emergent order
that's actually a wild idea right like
it's a really [ __ ] wild idea that
would even be possible
and you know the modern democracies came
following the enlightenment the cultural
kind of european enlightenment with the
idea
that we could have this thing called the
philosophy of science
where we could all measure the same
thing and get the same result
independent of biases
it didn't matter you know what we
thought beforehand if we measure the
speed of sound in the right way or
whatever it is we're gonna get the same
result so there's this unifying nature
of
objectivity that allows us to sensemate
together
which is why carl popper who advanced
the philosophy of science was the guy
who termed open society right that we
can do open societies based on
the ability to do shared sense making
using using a more methodological rather
than i had divine revelation and it's
true and you don't know
kind of approach and
and then but like we said the the idea
of governance is that there's some kind
of emergent
choice making or order at the level of
the choices we're making
the choices are both the result of our
sense making what do we think is
actually happening
what do we think the causes of what's
happening are and if we do
x what do we think will happen right
that's kind of forecasting sense making
but it's also what do we want to happen
which is our values which is not sense
making
right since making a sense in what is
the values is what ought what do we
think ought to be what do we really care
about so we can
call that values generation or meaning
making
so sense making and meaning making are
the prerequisites for choice making the
thing that we call governance in an open
society
is that there's some coordinated process
for choice making
that doesn't have to be imposed by a
king doesn't just turn into there's no
way we can get on the same page so it
has to be chaos
because we can sense the world together
and we can sense each other's values and
find a higher order set of values that
includes everyone so this is another
part of the enlightenment was the idea
that we could
do a dialectic on values you could say i
i really believe in doing x whatever
x proposition is we're like why do you
want to do it well because it's in
service of
uh decreasing infant mortality and the
value that you have is
infants and we're like yeah but if you
do that thing it'll be bad for this
other thing because it
whatever it'll damage the water supplies
what you care about the water supply
well let's not focus on the proposition
for a moment what you value
is children what you value is the water
supply let's hold all those as
legitimate values
right what you value is individual
freedom what you value is the
responsibility of the individuals to the
collective that
they are benefited by so the ability to
hear each other's values and synthesize
them and say a good solution will meet
everybody's values as best as possible
so often we get stuck with you know a
proposition is created
to meet some value before even looking
at what all the values are
and so it benefits the environment but
it hurts the economy or benefits the
economy and hurts the environment or
whatever it is
so those who feel particularly connected
to the thing being hurt are like this is
terrible we have to do everything to
fight it
and those who feel connected to the
thing that's being benefited are like
this is critical someone finally gets us
now those two sides have to become
enemies
if the only chance they have is to vote
on a pre-existing proposition that is a
shitty proposition because it was based
on a theory of trade-offs between those
it was never even consciously explicated
they never even said oh this is going to
harm this thing both these are values is
can we take these values and find a
better way forward a better proposition
that maybe could meet them both better
maybe
rather than that bridge that is going to
harm the environment the way that it is
um but it helps transportation which
will help the economy
a barge could do it without harming the
environment or we could just build
better local economies on both sides or
whatever it is right
so the dialectic process is where i want
to hear the values that you care about
and so you believe everyone needs to be
vaccinated or no one should be forced to
be vaccinated or everyone should have to
wear massage nobody should
what is the value you care about
independent of the strategy the strategy
is the way to fulfill value there is
something legitimate in the value even
if
then the sense making about is that
thing about vaccines or about masks or
about whatever is that true
is separate from is that value
legitimate right
and so if so we don't have participatory
governance in the us we don't really
in the world in any very meaningful way
we have the
the legacy story of it but we don't have
a population hardly anywhere
that are really seeking to understand
the world we live in
where they're where the government is
going to make choices on stuff
and for the government to be out formed
by the people that we understand enough
to be able to weigh in well
and we seek to understand our own values
and other people's values
and be able to have the dialectical
conversations to see if we're missing
some sense making somebody know some
stuff we don't we really want to hear it
rather than have
our in-group continue to feel right by
saying how dumb the people in the
outgroup are
so there isn't anything like
participatory governance which is why
open societies are basically failing and
doing shittily while the authoritarian
societies that aren't even claiming to
do that and are just doing top-down
government better are just doing better
at long-term planning and infrastructure
so you know people
will hear me talking about sense making
usually it's in this context of
how do we develop better capacity as a
society as a whole
for everyone to be doing a better job
making sense of the world than just
believing whatever happens to come
through the facebook feed that is
algorithmically optimized to appeal to
their current biases and
kind of limitly hijack or maximally
bother them
and drive in-group dynamics where
people's fear of being outgrouped by
believing the wrong thing and their
messes with subtle deep tribal biases
how can we do better job with sense
making at the level of training
individuals
at the level of how we change education
and train people
and at the level of the quality of media
we put out at the
level of how we design the information
architecture so that rather than a
facebook or youtube having an algorithm
to maximize time on site
that it does through appealing to your
biases which make you spend more time
it which makes people on the right more
right the left more left anti-conspiracy
theorists more hate conspiracy theorists
conspiracy series farther down that
direction
and so there's this just hyper
fragmentation as a result of the
the financial model of the information
technology
right so how do we make better
information technology
how do we make uh better media and
fourth estate how do we do better
education all those things so that we
can actually have better sense making
about what is real
better dialogue and communication around
what is meaningful what are the values
so that that those types of
conversations can lead to what would a
good proposition even be
it meets that factors all of what's real
as constraints
factors what matters as constraints and
works to find the best proposition
forward
so if we take as the background that's
the societal context
of where we're usually coming from and
talking about the needs for sense making
that was a long preface to then say you
want to bring it to the level of the
individual and say
all right so i'm not trying to fix
facebook's algorithms for sense making
right now i'm not
trying to necessarily fix participatory
governance or democracy or the fourth
estate or public education
i'm trying to say how do i as a person
do a better job of making sense
of the things that i should make sense
of that affect the choices i need to
make in the world
what things should i just actually not
bother myself with because i really
don't have a choice and it's not the
best use of my life energy
what thing should i or do i care to and
how do i do a good job and how do i know
if i'm doing a good job because
almost everyone that we're sure is wrong
is sure they're right
and so we are one of everyone that
they're pretty sure is wrong right
and so we should all be pretty dubious
of our own certainty
because statistically we're almost
certainly wrong
about most of things that we're sure
we're right about
that's dangerous right like it's
dangerous that
i'm clear about lots of things i think
other people are wrong about
and i'm clear about a lot of things i
think people in the past
were wrong about and i'm clear about
things that i was wrong about in my past
but i probably can't say anything that
i'd say i believe today
that's probably wrong
that's that's tricky because it's
probably mostly wrong
and so how do we
and now when ego gets tied up in that
right and then when belonging gets tied
up in that
if i don't if i don't say the right
narrative about
masks or about vaccines or about social
justice i'll be totally out grouped
right because now i'm a anti-vaxxer or a
sheeple
or whatever it is so there's a lot of
reasons to have everybody double down on
their worst
traits of
unwarranted certainty and sanctimony
so if we want to ask the question
how important is it to our own life to
develop our sense making how do we know
how well we're doing with it how do we
do it we can get into that
more absolutely one of the things that
i've got in my head there is
how much more considered and slow
decision making at the governance level
would have to be in order to factor in
all of these different
values and choices you know expediency
is something that people value
if the bridge needs to be built and
people think that it's going to make
their life better
but in order to factor in everybody's
different values it's going to take
two years of debating and planning and
all of the rest of it and
and that situation of consideration and
being moderate and and more uh nuanced
with your thinking
that happens at the individual level as
well right it's far easier to just react
take something that we think is the
closest approximation of correct
and just move forward no this is a
gibberish argument
so let's say we don't have clear sense
making
on a topic but we have to act
why do we have to act are there are
there real consequences or just made up
[ __ ] like an election cycle or
whatever that we could change the way
we're doing governance if there's real
consequences how consequential is it to
get it wrong
uh well it might be more consequential
than taking
more time right it depends there are
times where you have to make
consequential choices under uncertainty
we're not choosing fast enough is also a
choice that's a real thing
but it's that way less often than we
pretend that it is
and so then what is the consequence of
getting it wrong and doing something
much might be much more harmful
but also what's the what is the time
effect
of moving forward with something because
we just have to move forward
that a huge part of the world thinks is
wrong and bad and are going to actively
keep fighting like how efficient does
that end up being
they're all going to pay lobbyists
they're all going to help pay for
academics to sponsor counter narratives
they're going to pay for politician
uh candidacy processes whatever it is so
how fast does it
really end up being to try to advance
something
that half the world thinks is a terrible
idea
and so what you can see is we try that
we're like
no the the science is settled that's a
famous [ __ ] line on a million things
right
and you'll see it on both sides of all
kinds of things the science is settled
is just a nice way to say
my unwarranted certainty is true um
but the the science is settled
climate change the thing it is we got to
move forward we and we don't have time
to educate you dumb [ __ ] anymore
um about it and we're just you know so
we're gonna carbon trade this is the way
to do it or
cap and trade carbon tax whatever okay
well
how well does that work when all of the
groups are going to keep
lobbying against it and getting
republican candidates who will then try
to undo the laws in four years
that those you spend four years trying
to do the [ __ ]
knowing that the next four years will
undo all of it and actually
you never even plan on doing something
that won't have returns within those
four years because it won't possibly get
you elected and all the things that need
done need to have
10 20 30 50-year timelines and no one
will ever even look at it
and most of the time you're actually
just working on gaining political
support and campaigning to get reelected
so the expediency we just have to move
forward is usually a [ __ ] argument
for someone in a power position
moving forward in a way that will
advance their power position with
plausible deniability that it's
something else
if you want to move a civilization
forward
either you're moving forward in a way
that everybody's getting on board with
or you're deciding to use force to
oppress the fact that everybody's not on
board
or you're deciding to keep fighting the
fact that they also have force like
you just have to be realistic about that
it's interesting the option
of delaying a choice is also a choice
there's always a third option
of being more considered yeah i like
that okay so back down to the individual
how
how can someone become an adept
sense-making agent we're at the mercy of
certain things that
individually immediately we can't
control therefore
making the most of the capacities that
we do have is a good idea
i would not say the answer for this is
the same for everybody based on
what they feel called to their
dispositions their
their vocation and their kind of sense
of what their mission to do is
if someone is a nurse caring for
patients if someone is a mother raising
children
how much does them understanding what's
really
happening with the digital yuan and
whether it's going to become the reserve
currency of the world
or whether or not the u.s microgrids are
susceptible to emp
attacks like how much does their sense
making matter
how much agency do they have to do
[ __ ] anything about that pretty
little
how much does it likely stress them out
probably a lot
does that make them a better nurse or
mom probably worse could that same
energy be applied
to doing better sense making about
tuning into their children and their
patients better and where they actually
have some agency
so it when we recognize that sense
making is to inform choice making
right
do i have choice around this thing like
what is the basis of why i'm wanting to
do sense making is it simply because
i need to know which side of the
narrative where i'm on because i think i
have to be on one of the sides what if i
just don't what if i say i don't know
i don't i don't i don't know what i
think about systemic racism no you have
to know it but i don't
well you know and people can try to do a
forcing function then well then you're
complicit or whatever it is
okay well i can put a huge amount of
time and energy and then still not
actually have any real agency to move
this thing forward
given where i am in my life
but i can put that energy into studying
better nursing
or whatever it is right so i don't think
that the idea that like
everyone should be deeply informed about
all of the existential risks
and understand the entire effect of the
tech stack and globalization and
planetary boundaries and geopolitics is
like a thing that everyone should have i
don't think that's true
um so the first question is like
what matters for me to make sense about
based on what choices i actually have to
make in my life
that's an important question because
it's easy to get sucked into the thing
for somewhat unconscious reasons
now we can talk about how to do good
sense making on geopolitical
and environmental and complex scientific
topics there but the first part is make
sure
like make sure that the reason that you
feel called to do that makes sense
um and i'm of course not saying
that if you don't have a company or an
organization or you're not a politician
in
some way that can't directly affect that
thing you shouldn't know anything about
it there is something about general
informedness as a citizen that can have
value
but you do want to pay attention to like
i have finite units of life energy
and where do i want to put my attention
that is also connected to my creativity
so i want people sense making to be
informing their creativity
right to be informing their agency and
their choice making and the quality of
life for themselves and the people they
touch and for the world
at large as they can touch it
[Music]
now
how to actually do good epistemology we
can get into next but
does that does that part make sense yeah
absolutely i'm
interested to hear what the underlying
principles are presumably
there must be a structure upon which or
some commonalities
that all sense making agents whether
they be the nurse the government
official the creator the mother
are there some commonalities between all
of them
are there commonalities and how to do
good sense making in any domain
regarding
regardless of the domain sure they're
they're going to be different
there are certain places where it's like
how to get how to really get
this particular kind of backflip is not
something i get from reading wikipedia
like i only get it from trying to do
backflips like it's an embodied sense
making there's like
oh it clicked and i got it and there's
no amount of reading wikipedia that's
going over watching youtube that's ever
going to give it to me
so there isn't like one type of sense
making like
there's no amount of reading music
theory that will actually get my fingers
to grok how to play chopin
so there are different kinds of
creative capacities that require
different kinds of like
because you're sensing how something
works right sense making is not purely
cognitive it's taking your senses and
having a pattern emerge
sense making of like ah i got it we've
all had that experience playing the
piano we're trying to do the back flip
where it's like i got it
that's sense making of a type that's a
bunch of sensory perceptions
that came into a pattern where now i
have it in a way that can inform my
creativity
right
but i'll stick in the cognitive domain
for now um since that's
largely what what i think most people
were talking about
some super helpful basic tips
um if i'm trying to make
sense of a topic
that is conflicted with where the public
opinion
on it or even the scientific opinion or
whatever on it is highly conflicted
i should understand the conflicting
views before coming to one on my own
that's a that's a very helpful thing to
do so
um you know you were mentioning how do i
do better sense making of nursing well
let's say i'm a nurse and it's covet
time and there's like major conflict of
the cyber mectin work or not
and should we be doing this with people
and um
you know who do we think actually has
too much contraindication for these
vaccines or whatever it is like those
are places where a nurse would actually
maybe want to do some sense making
now they might not feel that they have
any time they might not feel the agency
that if they came to
think something different than hospital
policy they could do anything other than
get fired
but they still might care anyways
because they're like [ __ ] i i signed up
to this thing because of a calling and
an oath and i need to know
right so
one place there i like to start is i
like to see okay
are there two primary narratives or are
there a few narratives right let's
begin say there's two narratives uh
ivermectin really works and it's awesome
it doesn't work at all
and it's dangerous right typically
there's more than that typically there's
like five or six maybe it works early
case but not later or works for these
kinds of situations or there's some
indication works but we don't really
know or
um whatever but let's take
kind of primary narrative camps because
in today's
world most people are trying to sense
make between pre-existing narrative
camps
and it's kind of important to understand
there is a very strong incentive for
everyone to fall in narrative camps
they're basically these strange
attractors
and so there are underlying forces that
drive what you can
think of as polarization to rather than
just like well whatever is true
it's going to be it's much easier to
believe something is true that someone
with expertise says with a lot of
certainty and other people agree with
especially if there's a lot of
literature and i'm unskilled right now
of the time how am i going to read
all of it myself and then you get a
narrative and then you get people who
say that narrative has something false
with it and they do a
counter narrative that is usually an
anti-narrative that are also kind of
smart
and typically based on in either a
different emphasis and values hey this
is about personal freedoms this is about
public health
um this is about
my right to decide on my own body this
is about not being a grandma killer
whatever it is right
um sometimes it's just a difference of
values that affects their sense making
because they're sense making the thing
that seems most aligned with their own
values they're not
actually paying attention to the sense
making they're looking at the narrative
of truth that fits the value that they
seem to care more about
right i don't think anyone
should be comfortable with the idea of
more imposition on people's personal
freedoms than necessary and i think
everyone should be dubious of anyone who
feels that they are in a position to say
what is necessary and impose it by force
like everyone should be dubious oh you
have a monopoly of violence
that can impose necessary limits on
everyone's freedom
and who is the authority like what is
the authority process that is not
influenced by power
or [ __ ] up motives or ego or mistakes
at all that deserves to have that
[ __ ] power over everybody
like everybody should be legitimately
concerned about that
that there is such a thing as adequately
legitimate authority to wield monopoly
of power
simultaneously everybody should be
legitimately concerned
about
unnecessarily being a grandma killer
right like about
taking a risk as a young person it would
be not that consequential for you
probabilistically to be way more
consequential for other people and
everyone should have some sense of like
yeah we actually have a duty to each
other we have a social responsibility a
social feel that in so far as we're
affecting each other we're not just
automata
um and if we can affect each other
invisibly but still tangibly there's
real consequence to that like
even as libertarian as i want to be
non-aggression
i i don't have the right to come up and
hit you in the face right well do i have
the right to dump toxic waste in the
river on my property if you live right
downstream from me and that's the river
that
feeds your well no i'm aggressing on you
right
so if i'm sneezing and coughing in your
space
and i might have have an infection like
there's a real situation there regarding
what is the limit of personal
sovereignty and what is the limit of
civic duty
and everybody's comfortable and it's
interesting because a lot of people who
really like
libertarian sovereignty feel
comfortable the idea of civic duty to go
die and more
including where there's a draft if it
has to be right not just even where
it's voluntary so we're like okay there
is a relationship
between um
between the way that the individual
affects
the larger holes that they're a part of
and is affected by them
and so how do we maximize everyone's
liberty and maximize the well-being of
the whole
in a way that no one's liberty is unduly
harming anybody else's
right obviously we'd like to do that
with emergent order rather than impose
so rather than a law doing lockdown more
conscientious citizens who understand
more and care more would be better
right if you had citizens who cared more
and did the research better and really
came to understand it better
then they wouldn't need police they
would be self th
then you don't have to worry about who
is the authority that has a monopoly of
violence it's
there is a population
that is well educated conscientious
communicating with each other respectful
and self-policing in that way
right self-monitoring
so um so the point is that oftentimes
there are these values that have to live
in a dialectical relationship but we
will
forget that and focus on one of them
then we'll focus on the sense making
narrative that supports that one
and think and then we'll weigh it's the
scientists who believe in it as being
credible and when people quote them
we're like this is a credible scientist
but then when someone quotes the
credible scientist on the other side
we'll say
you're doing a logical fallacy of appeal
to authority
and it's like really you just did that
like it's an appeal to authority when
they
pick their scientists but this is a
credible person when you do it
um and that kind of subtle bias is just
all over the place right and it's
fundamentally a kind of bad
faith sense making that people don't
even realize they're doing most of the
time
so we call motivated reasoning motivated
reasoning is tricky
um and
there's so many reasons for it sometimes
i want to be certain just because
i'm [ __ ] scared to have to say i have
no idea what's going on about super
consequential stuff there's a pandemic
are the variants
going to get worse or is the vaccine
going to make them worse is everybody
going to die am i ever going to go
outside again
this guy seems really certain then the
story is not too scary or whatever it is
like
sometimes there's deep subconscious
stuff like my desire
for safety and certainty seems to be a
path to it
so the same place in people that gets
scared of the dark cause just when they
can't see what's going on they project
nasty stuff into it or they get scared
of deep water because when they can't
see what's going on
they project nasties happen to it uh
gets scared of the unknown in general
projects nasty stuff and then wants to
pretend there is no unknown so they want
excessive certainty about everything
so they get scared of death until then
they want to reject certainly about what
happens in the afterlife and make up
religions
um when you recognize
that how much of reality is
unknown and actually unknowable
there is no way through other than
actually
there's no way through well with grace
that doesn't involve deep
friendship with the unknown where you
don't project nastiness into the dark
spaces
you just say i don't know like just a
lot of things in life that have been
really interesting so far and i'm
curious
what happens right and i rather than
pretend that i know
and possibly steer really wrong i'd like
to just keep my eyes open and keep
paying attention
so i was giving one example of how
motivated reasoning and values and fears
and all like that
can affect people's sense making there
are other things that can affect people
sense making
get into but the first simple principle
you're saying across any domain
uh you know lab leak hypothesis
versus natural genetic origin or
anthropogenic climate change being
terrible really soon versus not or
whatever it is
find people who seem very well
researched
and earnest
who hold strong versions of the various
narratives
and see if you can study their narrative
and their reason for it well enough that
you can still man it you can be like i
actually really get and can give like an
essentialized version of this
then when you see the difference between
them see if you can come to understand
why like are they drawing on different
data
are they both cherry picking their data
and it's probably something that neither
of them are saying there
there's a lot of data and they're each
cherry picking they're each framing
um is one of them
following much more motivated reasoning
and less good empiricism than the other
one
but generally that dialectical process
where
one it'll point out to you where you're
faster to start to believe in something
rather than something else because of
your own biases
and if you notice that and you realize
that your bias will be
it's biased which means it misleads you
mislead bias is
like if i let go of the steering wheel
my car
starts going left i have to go actually
get it adjusted if i let go and it goes
right like that's dangerous i want to
let go and it stays straight
bias cognitively is the same thing it
means i'm going to be veering off of
reality
naturally based on what appeals as more
true or less true to me
because of various things right
dramas conditionings partial value sets
in group identities
the fact that the world of my childhood
is not a fair representation of the
whole world but i was really imprinted
that it was so i'll take those imprints
onto everything
so people should be fairly scared of
their own biases
right like they should want to seek out
and find their biases and correct them
and so anyone who's who gets upset when
someone says i think you're wrong about
something
is actually [ __ ] up their own life
if you if you protect your biases
because they're protecting some
sacred thing like your fear of
uncertainty or whatever
then you won't grow in this way and your
life will stay up or bound
at whatever the limit of truth that
those allow you to understand and
whatever vulnerable things are
underneath it
and whatever partial values are
underneath it but if if instead you're
like actually
i don't think i can navigate well on a
busted map
it just doesn't make sense any place
where my maps off i want to know
by definition i can't see my own blind
spots that's what a blind spot is
everybody has biases i can see everybody
else's i'm just pretty sure i don't have
any
the best gift somebody can give me is
where they actually tell me
if they're like i think you're off about
this now
they can be an [ __ ] and just judge me
or whatever and i still want to listen
maybe they're wrong but i want to listen
to see if there's possibly a gift in it
but if they're my friend they'll be like
look i know you're really trying i love
you i
agree with a lot of things i think
there's something you're missing here
i'm like tell me because the worst thing
i can imagine
is that i harm the things i care about
or serve what i care about
less well because of something i can't
even see and somebody saw it and didn't
help me
um so having this is another principle
of sense making
have friends that disagree with you on
really deep things like have different
biases if you're a liberal have
conservative friends
if you're strongly you know lgbtq etc
have traditionalist
friends um don't be so
sure that your moral set is the only and
superior moral set
that your sense-making set is the only
one have friends who have different
orientations and see if you can actually
see the world through their eyes in a
non-pejorative way
like oh yes i can see if i was as
uneducated and traumatized and like
whatever is them
um but see if you can actually be like
wow
yeah i i can feel
the clarity and rightness of seeing it
this way
and and and so have friends
see things differently and ask them
their take on things and listen and ask
their take on your take on things and on
you
um so this is one of the other things
that i think is
this is one of the other things very
destructive with social media is the
filter bubble phenomena
is uh since facebook is going to give me
what
it's not trying like there's not a
person having an agenda there's an
algorithm
that is optimizing time on site and it
just happens to be when i see
stuff that disorients me and i don't
i'm i'm getting less certainty when i
want more certainty i fail
but when i want more certainty and i'm
getting more in-group validation and i'm
only getting outrage at the out group
that makes me feel even more like i need
to double down or whatever it is i spend
more time so it just happens to be
that the appeal and i don't even know i
bail i just keep scrolling in the fast
infinite scroll because it didn't
capture my attention because there's so
much [ __ ] in the infinite scroll
that i'm only going to stop to look if
the person is hot enough
or if it looks like something that my
brain is pre-triggered to say that's
important
pre-triggered to say that's important
means appeals to an existing bias
and otherwise it's just scroll right and
just kind of don't even notice that i
passed it
but what that means is that i'm going
to have both content and people in the
nature of that world that will be
confirming my biases rather than
correcting them and so then of course
you will get increasing polarization on
everything as a nature of even just the
info
technology infrastructure itself right
people haven't seen the social dilemma
they should watch it it covers this
really well
um so
just to even if you keep facebook at all
or
whatever social media curate it
it for the most part the more time you
spend on it the less good your sense
making will be because
it is optimizing for something that is
not your sense making
but if you're going to use it curate it
so i went and
intentionally found
groups and public intellectuals that
represented opposite sides of every
topic and i
liked and followed all of them to just
confuse the [ __ ] out of the algorithm
because it's like who likes the sunrise
movement and the cato institute at the
same time and then what
you know um and then to be careful
because i know it pays attention that if
i'm going to like stuff i want to kind
of have a balanced distribution of my
likes
which can confuse other people socially
um but
it's because i want to see a
representative feed right
um and specifically i want to pay
attention to when i notice that i have a
leaning on a topic
i want to find the best thinkers to
disagree and i want to read their stuff
more
um to see am i missing stuff right like
is there anything in here i'm missing
so curating your algorithm that way is
helpful
getting the [ __ ] off facebook and just
doing better internet research than
than that or just following the
recommendations on youtube which are so
sticky they're so goddamn hard to avoid
especially because it's going to send up
some hyper normal stuff where pretty
soon you're just watching mma or
bloopers or something
um and did you like where did two hours
ago
and you're like oh i was doing internet
research and
um so just being real about how messed
up those algorithms are you're like okay
what is it i'm trying to get clarity on
what are the narratives and who are good
first let's just google who are the who
are the scientists academics thinkers
whatever that are
representing these well let me go read
some articles
right then let me find who's critiquing
those well
if i can get to the point where i can
make each of the arguments
as well as they can make it and then i
get a sense of why they disagree is it
different
data is it different values is it
different models
is it disingenuousness like why do i
think that
then i might be able to start to say do
i see a synthesis here
were they each cherry picking and there
is a higher order kind of
insight um
very often it's
you know it's looking at this cross
section in this cross section of a
cylinder and saying it's a circle
and a rectangle and there's partial
truth and they're just too low a
dimensional insight they're
hyper-focusing on a thing like
you know the founding fathers were slave
holders and the whole thing is
illegitimate and they built all of these
institutions justify slavery so
all of our institutions are built on
supporting that so it's institutional
racism everywhere and how can you
possibly like
say anything good about or quote these
guys and it's like
yeah and
the people
who want a better world than all the
racism and slavery
want a world that is aligned with the
declaration of independence more than
other articles
of governance written and
civil rights were slow but emerged out
of some of the structures that were
hippocratic as [ __ ] that emerged
and there was greatness in the nature of
what happened in the country so there
was like
evilness and greatness mixed together
and so i can make each of those partial
narratives by themselves adamantly and
talk past each other
but the reality is it's complex right
like some of the individual people
involved
were i have a friend gilbert morris
who's a professor on these topics and
he's like
benjamin or jefferson
was a great man and not a good man at
all and you have to hold both
like what is what does it mean to be
able to hold both of those because i can
tell each of those stories on their own
and they're both [ __ ] partial
stories
um so can i start to find a higher order
synthesis than either of the cherry
picked or
partial stories that's the thing i want
to start to look for
and then not just jump to artificial
certainty that now i got it i got the
whole thing right
i got something and there's probably
still lots of insights
so how do i stay oriented to continue to
gain insights so those few
things of make sure that what you're
being exposed to is the various
different ideas
make sure you're seeking to understand
them and synthesize them
curate your info environments
to support that and curate your friend
circles to support that those are a few
things
there's a sentence in crossfit that says
get comfortable being uncomfortable i
guess here it's
get comfortable with the unknown would
be an equivalent
and there is some it's very easy to have
uncomfort with the unknown so they're
related right
yeah and the reason crossfit says that
is because
comfort and growth don't happen in the
same place
um and
good sense making and
high certainty don't happen in the same
place yeah it seems to me that
it's going to be effortful you know to
do this to undertake
good sense making is going to require
you to go through
discomfort to go through unknown and to
spend a lot
more energy than just the limbic sort of
reflex action
there's a a quote from last year it was
in the times i've got this newspaper
clipping
um matthew syed i think identified it's
called compensatory control
he said when we feel uncertain when
randomness intrudes upon our lives we
respond by reintroducing order in some
other way
superstitions and conspiracy theories
speak to this need it is not easy
to accept that important events are
shaped by random forces
this is why for some it makes more sense
to believe that we are threatened by the
grand plans of malign scientists
than the transmutation of a silly little
microbe
15 months hence now with the lab leak
hypothesis this feels
uh even more sort of nuanced and
interesting but yeah i
am that competition i want to touch on
that for a minute
there was something that that writing
did i don't know
i don't uh hear who you said
did it so i'm saying this with no
allegiance or anti-allegiance
it presented a thought about
uh it presented a position on a
polarized topic
right the conspiracy theories aren't
true and this is just a
um and there weren't mad scientists
plotting and anything else and that this
was just a
bug it conflated that with
a high morals almost spiritual insight
that everybody would naturally
agree with and feel elevated by which
was
that um we've all had the experience
of feeling disorder and then seeking or
we start cleaning the house where we
procrastinated when we
our taxes come in we don't know how to
pay it we want to feel productive in
some way or whatever it is
like we've all experienced that thing
and so people like yeah that's true and
then they're like no it is true we
should
just be able to embrace the uncertainty
so there's like a resonant true thing
there's like an aspirational thing and
then there's like a given
a conclusion on a topic that is not
concluded is there
that's a kind of narrative warfare where
it almost makes it seem like believing
that belief
is aligned with the high moral almost
poetic like there's both a good
there's the ethical and there's almost a
beautiful aesthetic
and then the true right so so the best
narrative warfare takes the true the
good and the beautiful distorts them all
a little bit and braids them to align
with a particular position
and that's how i feel when i'm reading
like the new york times or something
where i'm like
if i believed anything other than this i
would just be a bad person like it's so
clear that
what moral high ground is and right side
of history and it's written so
beautifully like whoever wrote this a
[ __ ] brilliant writer and
um poetic it's achingly beautiful or
whatever
and and it seems so clear because
they're quoting the new england journal
of medicine and harvard and whatever it
is and it seems like the best scientists
all agree in the peer-reviewed journal
setting
that doesn't make it true like it really
it doesn't make it doesn't mean
that the morals that are there are like
so the lovely hypothesis is a really
great example
i have not done my research on it to
have my own opinion on it adequately so
i'm not going to but
i'm going to look at it just from a
narrative point of view
the loudly hypothesis
was up till whenever a couple months ago
you know like being a flat earther
right like a flat earth or anti-vaxxer
tinfoil hat wearing
reptilian baby blood drinkers run the
world um
and you know you you have to believe all
that nonsense and it's like
but even more it's like anyone who's
saying that could have leaked out of a
lab not only doesn't understand science
and it's anti-science but they're trying
to cause a war with china they're
xenophobic they're against asians
they're like like all this moral
sanctimony of what a bad person you are
what the bad effects will be and how
dumb you are if you think that it's
reasonable
that it might have escaped uh
a lab that happens to be in that area
that happens to work with those
viruses and because the science is
settled
because of something that we later came
to realize was not settled science
um and so you're like how and and so
then it starts to come out that actually
wasn't settled science
and we're like how the [ __ ] did the
zeitgeist get that powerful that quickly
that you were a dumb and horrible person
for believing a thing because the
science was settled and the science was
never settled and
everyone who believed the science was
settled and everyone else is dumb and
and bad should be reflecting like what
the [ __ ] i got captured
like i got captured i was certain about
something
and i didn't even read the article in
nature that proved
that it was certainly zoonotic
hypothesis and i'm not qualified and i
wouldn't have known how to do the
rebuttal that came out later
but the guy in in the new yorker whoever
was that wrote about it seemed really
certain
and and it appealed to my sensibilities
and the institutions that agreed with it
were the institutions that seem
high-minded that i like to agree with
um so
i i hope people take seriously right now
as an example regardless of where the
virus
actually came from the lab leak
hypothesis was not
dumb whether it was true or not it was
not proven false and was not dumb in the
way that was
said and the narrative and then like how
did that narrative get that like what
was the force that
wanted to make it seem that certain
and to push against the other narrative
so strong
that should be a very interesting
question
for everybody and
yeah it's fascinating in this whole
situation i have seen zeitgeist
formation
that is more intense and faster than
i've ever seen previously
that is not based on good sense making
but other stuff
just rapid news cycle iteration and yeah
i i
one of the terms that you use a lot is
talking about good faith and bad faith
actors
and um i guess that this ties in with
sense making
individuals or actors if you want to say
that sense making agents
um what i find
especially over the last 15 months and
the lab leak hypothesis is a good
identifier because it was so flagrant
and in your face
was people who had complete certainty
plus powerful distribution to be able to
convince others of their certainty
are able to reverse their position
essentially without an apology within
the space of 15 months
but it's here was a thing that i'm
certain is true
and now here's another story about a
potential other truth
without referring to the fact that the
first truth that we made you believe was
true
was untrue we saw this with um joe biden
last year where he said that
shutting down travel from china was
xenophobic in february
and then by may was saying that donald
trump had left it too late to close the
borders like you don't
get to do that you do not get to [ __ ]
do that you're supposed to be the people
leading the country
you're supposed to be the ones that we
hold to the highest levels
of good faith actor requirements
yeah that's cute um
like obviously they do get to do that
because
people are
uh easy enough to capture
and move along in that way
like that that's a that's why it happens
um what's interesting is
each time say a narrative changes
we made a mistake before we couldn't
have known or science takes time
which sometimes is true but now we know
right like it's always now we know so
what it's a continuous justification for
the authority we have
and um
the consilience project we just
published an article there recently
uh called where arguments come from
a team that worked on it did a really
really good job and
it basically shows like where do
arguments
in the public sphere come from like in
order for a lot of people to have heard
it
a lot of amplification of the message
had to happen
which meant a lot of people have the
ability to amplify a message had to care
about it
or some people that had the ability to
amplify it had to do a lot of work right
to make that happen
and so typically
there's a narrative that somebody who
has some vested interest wants
right so they have like a a demand for a
narrative
because it'll create a demand for a
thing in the population
and so they find a source of narrative
supply
they find a academic or a think tank or
whatever it is that already thinks that
thing
or think something close enough so they
don't have to get somebody to lie they
just upregulate the narrative that
currently wasn't like that person has
been writing about that thing for 30
years and never got any traction now
it's everywhere
because there's now an agenda that is
useful for it that will upregulate it
where before it was women upstream
and so it's important to just really
think about the mechanics of what
allows a meme to propagate what allows
the narrative or zeitgeist to propagate
and it's not just allows it what what
propagates it right there is energy
involved in propagation the energy has
an interest it's seeking roi on that
energy
and so this is why dc is filled full of
think tanks
that are intellectuals putting out
public policy
that is already predetermined in advance
what the ideology is they're doing it on
every new topic that emerges
right um
[Music]
yeah what do you think a good
sense-making agent
is not or what are some of the most
common pitfalls
that people have when trying to become
one
i mean we've been talking about the
pitfall of excessive certainty this
whole time
and epistemic certainty is i know what
is true
excessive moral certainty as i know it
is good also called sanctimony right
those are both pretty big pitfalls
there is another one on the other side
which is i don't know and i don't care
is nihilism
what i find interesting is that most
people will
or many people will flip from
[Music]
certainty to nihilism in like one step
um where they're pretty certain of
something if they find out that that's
not true they're like i can't make sense
anything
i'm giving up i'm gonna go watch tv or
whatever it is and
because the hard work of having to sit
in i don't know and i'm gonna work at it
and i'm still not going to know i'm
going to work at it more and i'm still
going to know for a long time
i have a bunch of friends that get
really frustrated with me because they
send me a thing and say what
what's your opinion on this thing
whatever it is and it's like something
about a different narrative on
early human civilization and hominid
origins or whatever it is and i'm like
they're like did you read the paper i
said yeah it's interesting
and they're like well what do you think
i'm like it would take me hundreds of
hours
to start to have a sense of it like i i
i
it's an interesting topic i don't have
the hundreds of hours to put into it
i'm not nihilistic and that i don't care
it just might not make it to the top of
my stack
um and a lot of the things that are on
the top of my stack i also say i don't
know
but i'm working on it right
um so when we talk about sense making
being good sense making agent like what
are we really like if we try to
make it simple and grounded
what we're saying is
i actually want to
understand the world i live in as best i
can
because i actually
hold that life is meaningful
and i hold that my life could be
meaningful
which means that my choices can be
meaningful
and so i want them to be informed as
well as they can be
uh if my choices are me acting on and in
and with the world
i want to understand things about me and
the world and about
what those actions will do as best i can
because if my choices really matter i
don't want to believe that it's going to
go a certain way and i'm wrong
unnecessarily and i don't like i want to
understand as much as
possible because i i cause it matters
right like ultimately because it matters
and i care
and then the hard part to say it matters
and i don't know and i might still have
choices to make
and i care
right it it's easier to jump to i know
or i don't care because that i don't
know and i care
and it's consequential and it's moving
it's [ __ ] hard right like that's
scary it can be heartbreaking but it's
like there's an epistemic humility
and an epistemic commitment at the same
time
i don't know but i can progressively
come to know better
right not all positions are equally good
positions some of them have more error
and some of them are more inclusive of
more perspectives
so i can progressively come to know
better so that my choices can be better
informed so they can be more effective
and more meaningful
but in order to do that i'm going to
have to stay the course of seeking
understanding for quite some time
which means i'm not going to have to not
prematurely come to think i already
figured it out just too quickly
or defer my sense making to someone else
who thinks they figured it out
easy exits out of the discomfort it's
deciding to give up halfway through the
workout it's sandbagging it so that you
don't
go to your maximum heart rate yeah it's
dropping the weight down so that the
discomforts a little bit less
yeah the get uncomfortable with the
unknown i think
is a really good sort of overarching
heuristic that you've got there
one of the things just one more way to
say that
get get okay with the unknown
like i there's a there's an even more
poetic and beautiful way to say it that
i actually
feel and think everybody feels if they
drop in
is actually connect
to your love of reality
if if you if you didn't care about
like if you didn't have a love for
reality wouldn't care if it got hurt you
wouldn't care if you lost it you
wouldn't care
like the fear of loss is because there's
something meaningful you don't want to
lose the anger at anyone doing the wrong
thing is because they're harming
something you care about
like care and love are the origin of all
the other emotions because otherwise
you'd just be apathetic and not give any
shits
right so ultimately i give shits about
things because
i there is a care and love about
life my life other's life's reality
that's real
so there is a love of reality that is at
the basis of the meaningfulness of
anything
and reality is mostly unknown to me i
know the tiniest fragment
so my love of reality and my love of the
unknown
right if i have a love of reality and
it's mostly unknown
that means not just comfort with the
unknown but and this is the awe at the
mystery this is the
spiritual sense of faith and trust
whatever right it's actually extending
the love of reality into the fact that
most of it's unknown
that's nicer we'll take that one
one of the things that i was very
interested in is to try and work out
what stage of personal actualization
people should start to serve the world
at large
should we sort our own [ __ ] first before
trying to go and fix the world and
when do you know when you're ready for
one of a better term
yeah definitely total enlightenment
before sweeping the kitchen
um
i i joke because it shows how ludicrous
it is to think that it
is not both always right um
if i am seeking to help the world
and i have not learned what's going on
in the world i might be doing stuff
that's totally not needed
or not very useful i'm trying to solve a
problem but i don't understand the
upstream things that are causing the
problem so my actions will mostly be
useless
right so do i want to
work on myself in this place just means
work on my cognitive models and maps
that i understand the issue well enough
i can be helpful
right sometimes i care about the thing i
want to help but the first thing is do i
understand the problem well enough
to be able to help right sometimes that
doesn't matter there's trash on the
beach and pick it up
did i fix the issue of trash on the
beach no i don't know who's putting the
trash there why
what cultural effects are causing that
so but i still picked up the trash that
day
cool that is not a comprehensive
solution to pollution
it's a meaningful activity in the moment
but um to the degree i want a
comprehensive solution to pollution i
have to start to understand the
financial incentives to make throw away
plastics i have to understand what it
would take
technologically to be able to make
plastics that biodegraded i have to
understand the
culture of why people do that here and
they don't in japan and how we could
change the culture
there might be a number of ways i can
come to understand it well enough right
so i might want to work on my
understanding of the
a problem before trying to help it so
that i have a sense of how to really be
effective
um particularly the more complex the
issue is the more consequential it is
and the more consequential my
action is gonna be right oh
we're gonna do a solar
uh uh
remittance program where we that's not
the right word
um but where we reflect 20 of the
sunlight
out of the earth for geoengineering
should probably be pretty [ __ ] sure
pretty [ __ ] sure that that's a good
idea because it's pretty
consequential right or we're we're gonna
try and sequester co2
using these genetically modified plants
that we've never planted at scale and
don't know the biological effects of the
modified
organisms like more sense making
before choices that are really
consequential
so that's one example of i want to work
on my own
cognitive maps of what is needed what's
going on what would be effective
enough that i have a sense of what to do
but then also there's a point at which
there's no more research that will work
i need to field test the thing
try some stuff and be like oh it didn't
work for reasons no the lab
never told me i didn't realize that the
locals don't even like that thing or
they don't believe it or
and so there's a place where the
application layer also ends up being
part of the epistemology it's the
testing right
um so that's one example there's also
the example of
what if i'm working on trying to help
the world and it's not
the problem isn't a lack of cognitive
development it's a lack of certain kind
of emotional healing and development
where
um that is affecting how i'm showing up
well
let's say whatever
wounding issues in childhood
have me have an outsized need for credit
seeking
because of not having ever felt loved
enough or enough or
only having felt good enough based on
performance and credit attribution
whatever
will i possibly mess up a project to
ensure that i get the credit out of it
where i'll undermine other people or
sabotage or whatever it is or
emphasize to me getting credit more than
the effect of the project
where me doing work on not needing that
as much because of healing whatever
kind of place that is in me would
actually make me a much better agent
for change in the world yeah that's like
a real thing right that's a real thing
where that kind of stuff
messes stuff up or where
i am trying to heal a particular issue
in the world that i don't realize is
unresolved wounds in me where i see
something resonant out there and when i
heal the thing in me i have a totally
different assessment of it
right like i have a totally different
assessment because i really
i was trying to fix marriages in a
particular way because of my
trauma around my parents divorce or
whatever it was and so i was seeing it
through a traumatized lens i didn't even
realize that i had this whole mission
and non-profit and whatever it is
so there are times where our own trauma
will get projected on the world this is
why lao tzu said if you want to protect
your feet from rocks better to put on
shoes and try to cover the world in
leather
right that idea of like but that doesn't
mean
that any pain you feel looking at the
world is just your pain
like i think if someone was as healed
and integrated
as they could be and they see a factory
farm
they would feel the empathetic pain of
the pain of those animals if they see
hungry kids they feel unempathetic pain
if they didn't there would be something
wrong with them they wouldn't be
enlightened they'd be sociopaths
um and this is why you see the buddha
crying right this is where you see the
the passion of the christ is the idea of
the enlightenment is not just oh i can
see you suffering and doesn't do
anything to me
it's like sociopathic enlightenment is
not that interesting
it's but this is where it can be either
way
right am i clear and i'm really feeling
the pain of the other feeling called
to help or is the
some pain somewhere else just triggering
my pain and then rather than face it in
myself i'm gonna try to solve it in the
world
in a way that will always keep my sense
making and my effectiveness off
right so these are examples that people
will give people understand this is like
you do more work on yourself first or my
own need for excessive certainty
because of my uncomfort with the unknown
that will make me do [ __ ]
where i'm i'm
wrong but certain i'm right too often
right these
and we i'm sure the listeners can
generate a hundred more examples
so should i just do a bunch of
psychotherapy and a bunch of zen
meditation
and a bunch of uh study
until i am second tier or third tier or
whatever the [ __ ] the developmental
metric i want to look at is
that means i am now whole enough and
integrated enough that i can work in the
world
no that's ridiculous um
you can't even like so many of
the ways we learn about the problems is
by engaging with them
and you couldn't only do it in study and
so many of the ways we learn about our
issues is by engaging in the world and
seeing oh i really did
try to get too much ego credit there and
i'm reflecting on it and i was an
[ __ ] and like i need to work on that
and i wouldn't have seen it
otherwise or wow that project failed and
i was so certain
that's how i'm seeing my certainty issue
right so as i heal and learn and grow
i can show it better in the world but as
i show up in the world i also get to see
those things
if i'm looking for them if i don't look
for them i'll always blame the world
every failure was somebody else's fault
right every but if i'm looking
for it then i can see those things and
rather than just get crushed i'm a piece
of [ __ ] that's all there is to it
i can take it as oh this is this was
some
belief trauma pattern that created a
self-fulfilling prophecy or whatever but
that i could shift
right so i want to bring in empowerment
where i will look at
what in me was off not to just beat
myself up and hate myself
not to pre or not to pretend there was
nothing in me off but to be able to see
it look
at it work on it integrating it going
past it
but similarly uh there's also this thing
that we're showing up to the world
with things that we're passionate about
it motivates our growth
because let's say
i'm afraid of public speaking let's say
i'm like catatonically afraid of public
speaking
i can just avoid that forever and don't
have to go through it
but let's say i'm somebody
like jane goodall or whatever and i go
and i'm working with the
with the primates in the wild and i
watch the poaching
right and i'm so [ __ ] broken by that
and it matters so much more than whether
the people like me or not i get up on
stage and talk about it and like we have
to stop this position we have to
because something bigger than me and my
fear of public speaking
is actually not moving me
and if when i get up on the stage to
talk i'm still in the like are people
going to like me or not like me
place i won't get over the fear if i'm
touched by something that
is so much more important than that i
can actually transcend that because it's
not about me i'm talking about the topic
i'm talking about the issue i don't even
talk about give me the [ __ ] off have
somebody else talk about i'll just talk
about if there's nobody else who's doing
it
so i also find that like the the hardest
parts of our healing are hard
right like we avoid those things for
reasons we don't notice them they're in
the shadow for reasons
and oftentimes this is why like so many
people only
heal patterns when they have kids we
see this laws because there's something
bigger than them for which they're
willing to work because they're like man
i'm [ __ ] my kids up the way my
parents [ __ ] me up i
told myself i wasn't going to do this
i'm repeating the same patterns i see
they're going to get it
and that's the only thing that has them
like double down on what it takes to
shift that
so whether it's your kids or whether
it's some other calling there's a place
where showing up to the world
is actually the only thing that can make
something more important than you that
can allow you to transcend the parts of
self that were just too hard otherwise
so what we want is a virtuous cycle
between
growing as a being and having who we are
show up for what we care about and where
as we show up for what we care about
it gives us insight about ourself
about the situation and it gives us
motivation and as we
grow and heal more as a person we can
show up to what we care about better
that's beautiful have you got any sense
of whether you think on the whole people
tend to er more toward the side of
showing up or more toward the side of
working on themselves first if you were
to give
most people a little bit of a push in
one direction would you say
consider the outside or consider the
inside more
they're just different groups of people
right you have a
personal growth world uh and a kind of
psychotherapy and healing world and the
call it eastern enlightenment world that
is
very focused in that direction you have
a entrepreneurial
and um activist and various types of uh
action-oriented
folks in that direction biases on both
sides
yeah have you considered the potential
that humans are just too at the mercy of
our emotions are programming
to be able to reach our civilizational
potential
i was thinking about this when the most
recent uh potential release about aliens
was
coming about and i had a conversation
with a friend saying
i don't think the aliens could be even
10 percent more emotional
than us by whatever criteria you want to
cause that more emotionally reactive
because coordination would become so
difficult if you turn it up to maybe 10
or 20 percent more
that you'd be able to achieve [ __ ]
like have you considered that that we
might just be kind of bouncing off a
glass ceiling that
the creatures that we are are so
self-limiting that
no matter how much we try to transcend
our own programming that we are sort of
destined to fail
um yeah so
this is the there's a common question
of that i've received many times of like
do i actually
get human nature and yeah
that's good human nature
well they're related questions okay
right
it's a related question and it usually
comes in the form of
i'm dubious of two things i'm dubious
that people can be
uh or i'll say it another way i i'm
concerned that people are too irrational
and too rivalrous to do anything like
this emerging coordination shift you're
talking about
um that the level of rationality and the
level of anti-rivalry
right so like wisdom and compassion or
whatever it is that would be needed
don't seem to be well demonstrated
across the population anywhere so what
kind of aquarian nonsense is this
um and uh
so let's address that it's a real
politic critique right or
concern am i asking the same thing
you're asking
not far off yes i mean i i wasn't
accusing you directly it was
more abstract but yes yes you're right
yeah have i ever
considered yeah um so
i'll tell you the the first part of how
i
approach this so in the same way i'll
actually use it as an example of when i
was saying a good way to sense make is
to do dialectic
so everything on the nature versus
nurture arguments
and the range of what people thought
nurture could do
were topics i really wanted to see what
were all of the the thinking and what
was the basis for the thinking
and were there any kind of axioms that
were unquestioned or new possibilities
that could change the landscape
from even those ideas
so uh one thing
is when we look at say how violent
versus altruistic or
rational or whatever metric we want to
look at however we assess looking at
across a population to get some kind of
distribution
um first i would say i'm extraordinarily
dubious of pretty much
all social science of this type for a
bunch of reasons
um one is
it almost all started post industrial
revolution and much
more recent than that and almost all of
human history that conditioned us
uh genetically and otherwise was in
tribal environments
and those are so different and just like
we're saying even the nature of facebook
engaging with it changes the patterns of
what we think feel
believe react to um and there's
tests that facebook has run of like we
can make people more depressed and
happier and believe different things
just by putting what's in the out
change in the algorithm a little bit
right so
post ubiquitous capitalism in ubiquitous
industrialization and ubiquitous nuclear
family homes and
a bunch of things none of which were
natural to the human evolutionary
environment
but their conditioning that kind of one
and so it became an ubiquitous
conditioning we do the social science
then
and then pretend that that's not
conditioning and call it human nature
because of ubiquitous conditioning
that's silly right um and then there's
so few indigenous people left or
whatever we can just make them
statistical outliers
um even though they have very very
different patterns on a lot of those
things also so that's one reason that
i'm very
dubious of the social sciences and this
is even like when they're trying to do a
good job
not like like the nonsense
social science that was
uh reifying why whites were superior in
the early
u.s based on bad interpretations of
darwin and phrenology and stuff right
but you can see from that stuff how
easily
bias influences something as complex as
social science complex and consequential
the other thing is that there are a lot
of things about people's behavioral
dispositions that change with
development
and development is not factored we don't
factor
levels of higher stages of human
development post
just be becoming 18. even though they're
very real things we just
put it all together under a bell curve
but
you know when you look at the work of
piaget and then the kind of
neo-piageti and educational philosophers
who are looking at human development and
childhood it's very clear there's
neurologic development and corresponding
change in fine motor skills and logic
skills and verbal skills
etc and we get to like 18 schools over
and then development ends
right and that's a fully developed
person that's gibberish right like
that's not a fully developed person
so what is development beyond that so
you have a bunch of people
who have worked on higher stages of
development and
zack stein's a good colleague of mine
work on that very heavily and looked at
the work of
kohlberg and graves and lots of people
who've worked on that but it's like
the complexity of someone's cognitive
model the development of their
moral models the development of their
aesthetic the development of their
capacity to perspective take
perspective seek and perspective
synthesize those things keep developing
right or they can keep developing one
can do things to help them
and then at those higher developmental
capacities there are different
behavioral dispositions
and this is not just typologically
they're typologically left or right or
whatever this is
um but they're so we could say
if the society was supporting more
development of that type
you would have a totally different bell
curve right
and but that's not a topic that's
usually factored
so there's a bunch of things like this
where i would say the social science all
needs taken with some grains of salt
one thing i have looked at is on the
traits that matter most
to a civilization that would work well
i've looked for positive deviance
outliers of the statistical norms on the
positive side
to see is there an upper is the
is the upper boundary that we think of
really the upper boundary
or are there places where what we think
of as the upper boundary is the medium
right like it's quite different and so
if you there's heaps of examples but if
you look at like
through much of the last few thousand
years across lots of different
cultures uh and different geographies
have jewish families raised better
educated kids than the people around
them
much of the time yeah they have
and and so is there are there cultural
dispositions
that can lead to um
higher qualities of education and
correspondingly different qualities of
ways of being right different types of
disposition so then you have
that for a long time the jews all as a
diaspora pretty much didn't defect on
each other
right and the way
the jewish law is structured
there it's kind of like a formal logical
system so
they're also getting very good at how to
be able to think in formal
ways which makes them good at which is
why they became good at
science and finance and other things
that were
thinking and formal logic was relevant
it's a really important example because
you could say well
if what jewish culture gave
in terms of the development of education
and rationality and non-defection on
each other could happen across the whole
population would that change things
yeah it really would what about the
jainists
do you have a religion where across a
long period of time nobody hurts
bugs or plants yeah you do
how do what about the violent kids in
the society what about the sociopaths
across a huge population the the
violence bell curve is completely
different
right you have extraordinarily low
violence across the whole population
how can that be well they're they're
developed differently
can you have a population where almost
everyone is violent yeah there's a few
cultures
where violence is ubiquitous right
um and you can see in cultures where
kids
grow up as child soldiers that you don't
make it to adulthood without killing
people
and so it's like the janjaweed and the
jains
are both possible in human nature
depending upon conditioning
so the idea that what we naturally are
is the median of that is just gibberish
it's just not understanding how we
create societal structures that create
conditioning that support the societal
structure
so what if we had something that was
conditioning non-violence and compassion
more like jains or buddhists or quakers
and conditioning rationality more like
nordic buildum countries or jews and
what if we had a few of those things and
we brought them together into not just
an educational but a cultural
developmental system
could we have is it within human nature
if rightly conditioned to have higher
potentials
yeah it totally is within human nature
of rightly condition of higher
potentials
what if in addition we created an
economic system where we addressed
perverse incentive
so rather than the guy who externalizes
the most harm
to the environment makes the most money
and then gets the most checks and status
and whatever to
actually all of the harms the
externalized harms are internalized to
the cost
so the guy who gets the most money is
the one who does the most omni benefit
and no harm
anywhere well now there's no sociopathic
niche to condition bad behavior and bad
values in people and doing the thing
that's good for others ends up being
good for you
actually is conditioning the values even
from self-centeredness right it starts
to bridge them in that way
well how do we make an economic system
that rigorously internalizes
externalities and addresses perverse
incentive that's a really deep question
for changing what we would call
human nature that isn't human nature
it's the nature of of
made-up human coordination systems right
does all property law does all access to
resource have to be at the level of
individual private property
no can we do things that change that
fundamentally
is every good fundamentally rivalrous
because it's scarce no digital goods
made it very clear that you have things
that are not only
not scarce but anti-reverse the more
people that use them the more valuable
it becomes but we still make them
artificially scarce
because of the artificially scarce
dollars because artificially scarce
materials economy
can we make a materials economy that
isn't artificially scarce by making a
closed loop with enough energy to run it
yeah we can't
so the point is do we see
positive deviance of you know you
you look at a very wealthy population
old wealth families while they still
have
the integrity of how to do dynasty or
even just
the kids going to the best prep schools
in the u.s
right and then who go to the best ivy
league schools and have all the best
tutors
do you have the same distribution of
success in life of the kids coming out
of exeter and the kids coming out of an
average public school
no they're totally different well what
if everybody went to exeter and
had that corresponding life since they
were little what would be totally
different
well but we can't afford to do that yeah
so that here's the thing
the idea of the dumb masses is class
propaganda
because the upper class that has access
to the things that develop them having
more capacity
is why they end up having more capacity
is a major part of why they have more
capacity
and then the idea that some people like
them need to be in positions to rule
because the masses are too dumb
is a self-fulfilling prophecy because
then we'll keep the masses dumb
by not giving them better educational
resources and other types of
you know things that would create a
difference there so i
like i actually think that the idea of
the irrationality and the rivalrousness
of the masses
is one of the deepest
parts of like propaganda zeitgeist of
ruling classes forever because it
justifies the basis for rulership
cultural conditioning masquerading as
human nature in the modern world
is something that i've never even
thought of before that is
so interesting
yeah i mean if you look at you know
you've run these clubs and you see all
these teenagers coming to the clubs and
how they behave and so
you've seen patterns that are on repeat
so much you're like i know human nature
i've seen this
100 000 times right but if you
went to the tribes in the western amazon
and saw how the
teenagers there were engaging who'd
already been doing ayahuasca for 10
years since the time they were little
it's not the same like there are some
things yes they have a sex drive
right yes there are certain aspects of
paying attention to social hierarchies
that everyone's going to notice
but there's more that's different like a
lot more that's different right
um that's conditioning
given the fact that at the moment the
cultural conditioning
appears to be making human nature into a
rivalrous game
it's difficult we have coordination
problems we not everybody is a jain or a
jew
at the moment or some perfect
amalgamation of both
um with that in mind you said something
in our first conversation that was
where gods were just shitty gods and it
was a comment on the difference between
technological prowess and sort of
wisdom or ability to deploy that
technological prowess
if you could do you think it would be
optimal to curtail
technological development but perhaps a
a couple of millennia say while we let
our wisdom
catch up or do we risk more by
accumulating background risk
and potentially uh losing galactic real
estate by not progressing within that
time
have you got any sense of how that
balances
it's irrelevant because it's impossible
it's impossible to slow the progress
much if you had a god's eye view
if i had a god's eye ability to slow it
would i
yes um well if i had the god if i had
the god's ability to slow it i would
just speed up the rate of the wisdom
um because it's not easier like
what it takes to grow the wisdom of
everyone and what it takes to stop the
progress are actually the paired thing
because outside of the wisdom the
multipolar traps win
anybody who says i'm going to get there
first
is going to just win the world because
there's so much power so now
they have everyone has maximum incentive
to get there as fast as they can
including lying to other people about
that they're not doing it so people
aren't trying to race
and so so you know
you can say god we are not ready to be
stewards of this much technological
power let alone power that we won't even
be stewards of because it'll become
autopilot can run itself like agi
right um so we need to just slow this
[ __ ] thing down okay so we can become
a unabomber
which that was his idea right ted's idea
was like we we're not ready for tech
like we we sucked with spears we were
[ __ ] with spears we were [ __ ]
with guns we were [ __ ] with icbms
and now we're going to have like drone
weapons everywhere like no we got to
slow that stuff down because we have
been [ __ ] with all the weapons we've
had and all of the
we've destroyed environments with way
less capacity than we have now
okay so you come to that
idea and you you can do what if you
don't have tech you don't have the power
to affect stuff
because the tech ends up being the power
so other people disagree with you and
they want the power
so if you want to stop them you got to
get more power than them which means you
got to beat them at the race to get the
power to be
to stop them
so the techno optimists
the naive techno optimists who just say
tekkel solve all the problems this is a
gibberish position it's not just
gibberish it is
super dangerous in my opinion it's the
most dangerous world view currently
because like
a militant jihadi worldview doesn't make
a.i and crispr
tech and things like that it just
doesn't make the tools that can be tools
of destruction at scale
only the the world view that supports
the
increased rapid development of
exponential tech
is the thing that increases the
destruction
the fundamental destruction power not
just the application of the existing
destruction power
right so the idea that
the faster we build the stuff the better
everything will get because the ai will
just solve all the problems and we can't
possibly solve it so let's just get to
the ai fastest let it solve all the
problems and etc
like yeah that's an extraordinarily
dangerous view
the luddite view right the techno
pessimist who says
we have always been bad stewards of
power we cannot wield exponential power
well
um we've used powerful war exponential
war destroys everything
we've used power to extract from the
environment and externalize the cost
exponential externality destroys
everything uh we've used our power to
create radical asymmetries of power
exponential asymmetries of power sounds
like a shitty world for almost everybody
um so so why
like we need to stop that thing well
that view
while it's true that view ensures that
it will have no power to do anything
right um
so the only view that can
forward is the one that embraces the
tech that is where the power is
but embraces it recognizing that it's
not a given that that tech is good
it could be developed in ways that are
positive but it can also
like if facebook wasn't developed with a
time-on-site maximizing algorithm
it could be a very different force right
like the ability to
to take all of my behavioral data make a
advanced psychographic profile on me and
then use ai to curate an infinite news
scroll to affect
my mind and behavior that's [ __ ]
powerful tech but if the goal is
optimized my
time on site to sell me and my
information to advertisers
then it's going to optimize for putting
in front of me the limbic hijacks and
the
cognitive bias and the in-group and the
things that drive addiction but
if it's desire if if it was optimized
for
developmental metrics of like expose the
person to the things that will actually
help them see alternate views that they
don't already see and help them learn
and grow and perspective seek and
like it could be techniques like that
could be the most powerful tools of
consciousness elevation and education
that have ever been
so it's not that the technology is
definitely bad it's it and it's also not
that the technology's value is agnostic
it's not values agnostic no technology
is about as agnostic
i if i make a plow
it's not values agnostic that can be
used good or bad the plow will make a
lot more food for my people than just
hunting and gathering
so that means that if other people use
it and i don't
i'm just going to lose in terms of
making it through famines and having
stuff to trade and whatever
so i have to use the plow as soon as it
exists pretty much
right and the plow codes a pattern of
behavior now i have to yoke an
ox and beat it all day long to do that
so i before i was animistic when we were
doing hunting gathering i'd kill
the buffalo every once in a while but i
believed in the spirit of the buffalo i
can't believe in the spirit of the
buffalo and beat it all day long
after cutting its testicles off and
putting something through its nose and
whatever
so i have to change my whole view on the
spirit of the animal right
was the tech values agnostic no it coded
values into me by my using it by the
fact that i had to use it for game
theoretic advantage
right so the idea that tech is just tech
it
it's not good or bad it's how we use it
this is a misunderstanding
yes of course i can use a hammer to
build a house for the homeless or beat
somebody's skull and it's a positive or
negative use but it's also
the hammer will code certain patterns of
behavior those patterns of behavior will
end up coding values into me
right and so
um
so what it means is if i have
social tech i can develop
social tech that is in like facebook
right i can develop a social technology
knowing that it will code patterns of
human behavior that will code their
values and how they see the world i can
develop it intentionally
that will code patterns of behavior and
values
that some model of human development
says is actually a more developed person
versus
is a more attention extracting and
profit extracting person which usually
means a less developed person
so it's not that detect is values
agnostic and it's not that
it's necessarily good as the technology
mistakes are necessarily bad it's that
we can design it in a way where the fact
that it's not
values agnostic and it will be
conditioning values can be good or bad
but it comes not just
how we use it but how we design it right
the nature of the design itself
will end up affecting the use patterns
which will end up affecting the beings
in the society so
in order to forward we have to both
utilize the technologies that have power
otherwise the stuff we're doing just
won't matter
those who are utilizing it will just win
but we have to do it in a way that is
also aligned
with the human development and the
social values and the integrity of the
the planet and the commons that we want
to see so right now the exponential
technology
like it's fair to say that exponential
tech is in
confers so much more power than all
other legacy forms of power that only
those
who are developing and guiding
exponential tech will have much say in
the future
right now there
is like two attractors for what happens
either the exponential technologies
um just cause catastrophic destruction
because you have exponential warfare or
exponential externalities
right or we figure out how to avoid
those by some
good control systems using the tech and
now we get exponential control
control systems and so we see
authoritarian nation states
using the tech to make better
authoritarian nation states and we see
some companies using the tech to make
companies that are more powerful than
countries but they don't have
jurisprudence up formed by the people
right and so that is like more like a
new kind of feudalism
so both the authoritarianism and
feudalism are like technologically
empowered
autocratic structures so there's
basically
catastrophes and dystopias are the only
two things that are currently
on the landscape if we want something
that
is not a catastrophe and not a dystopia
then we have to
utilize the tech in a way that binds the
tech
so it doesn't cause the catastrophes
that does it in a way that's not
dystopic
meaning that the order is emergent
rather than imposed how do we utilize
these
just how do we utilize ai and and crypto
and social and attention tech and all
these things how do we utilize them
to increase collective intelligence and
collective coordination
so that we get increased effective
coordination and order
without it being a kind of dystopic
control system like there's a lot of
innovations we can really implement
there so the question of should we
slow down the rate of progress if i
could like if
if i could slow it down and just say hey
the guys who are getting way too close
to super dangerous ai
if i could slow it down i'd yes yes i
would like that
um because right now our growth in doing
it rightly and wisdom
is not good relative to our growth of
getting the technology more powerful
if i could get like how powerful
crispr technology is becoming as cheaply
as it's becoming to slow down
so that it wasn't so easy to have very
small groups at bioweapons capacity like
yes i i would like that to slow the [ __ ]
down it's not going to because there is
no
world authority that can stop it
everywhere and anyone that does it is
advancing so that nobody really wants to
stop it
so what we have to do is get the
utilization of those technologies to a
better attractor that can guide them to
happen even faster
the consideration of what sort of a
world we would be in if facebook
optimized for
well-being or happiness or insight or
whatever
we think about how powerful it is and
some of the changes that we've seen in
human nature which we now know might
very well be cultural conditioning
it's it's crazy i just think about the
sort of
thing about the sort of society that we
would have if you had
mult or you so you prefer to learn
through 15-second video clips okay
tick-tock education is tick-tock
mindfulness is for you and then
oh you prefer to actually read but you
can you get away with more pithy sort of
aphoristic stuff okay so twitter
enlightenment that's your place
like yeah and like
okay let's take so the type of media we
give people
but then also the nature of the content
to be
biased challenging more than bias
confirming
um i don't know
so if you take uh there are some
youtube channels and facebook groups
that just document police violence
and so you can just watch videos of cops
beating the [ __ ] out of people
in ways that seem unprovoked and some of
them are just cops beating up black
people
and as much as i am aware
of the statistics and i'm aware of how
we're affected by this i can't watch
that channel for more than a few minutes
without just
seeing red everywhere right like and and
that's the only issue i can care about i
can't care about anything else in that
moment
and then you watch a different channel
that is a blue lives matter
one that basically just shows cops
risking themselves to protect other
people and then people attacking cops
which is why they
are the way they are um and maybe one
that just shows black people attacking
cops
and then you're like [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
up job that is and how amazing they're
doing and how much self-restraint and
and now neither of these are giving me
statistical representations
right i just watched four videos now
there's a million interactions
or thousands of interactions in every
city every day right and there's all
kinds of complexity in this
um and i didn't even watch what happened
leading up to it
but if i'm a if i'm a black person
living in
some inner city area and i watch a few
of those videos and it
profiles me and it shows me more of
those because i spend time on site
because it [ __ ] hurts
i'm just getting vicariously traumatized
right by watching someone that looks
like me that i resonate with get [ __ ]
killed or beat up or whatever
and and so what does that do
but then the other guy who's watching it
who's watching the other one right the
guy in texas watching the blue lives
matter
one is getting more and more
both patriotic and he's getting
vicariously traumatized of the way the
cops are being wrongly attacked
by the black lives matter folks the
protesters whoever it is
and that person is actually becoming
more racist than they were
right becoming more scared and so what
if they got the other videos
like what if the algorithm was actually
giving them the other content and what
if it was
giving them the specific subsets of the
other content that would be likely to
actually touch something
and appeal to something in them so that
there was just some
so one it wasn't just just traumatizing
them and two it might be
giving them some insight how to do
something other than culture war
how to do something that could possibly
bridge where there's trauma on
different sides simultaneously so if you
start to think about
let alone the science of yay or no on
ivermectin
right or whatever so if you start to
think about could we curate it to have
the right media forms
and the right distribution of the types
of content
and exposure to the types of people that
would help this person be more
trans-perspectival more perspective
seeking more perspective taking more
holistic in their thoughts and insights
yeah i mean it's and and even where in
so far as someone is watching something
and it's their liking and it's being
seen what they're
watching where where insofar as like
status [ __ ] is being hijacked
we use it for the right thing where
people start to have status confirmed
by the amount of stuff that they're
looking at from different perspectives
and it's educational in nature
um i think it's fascinating to start to
think about
and and still people be scared hearing
this like who the [ __ ] thinks that they
know what human development is and what
i should see and is going to socially
engineer me for their good idea
and they should be dubious of that the
thing is you're being socially
engineered right now and you and you
never
aren't right so it's not like socially
engineered or not it's
bring consciousness to the fact that it
can't not happen
because we are all conditioned by the
environments we're in and then take
responsibility to say
how do we how do we actually do that
intentionally well what does that mean
i mean at the moment i'm sure that there
would be a way to make it worse to make
it more polarizing or more limbically
hijacked
but it feels like there's a lot more
ways to make it better than there are
ways to make it worse
it's interesting the ways to make it
worse
the search algorithm orients there
better it's like
is it possible to make food that is much
worse for you than hostess and
mcdonald's well like only if it's not
food at all it's just poison
right like if i'm doing just pure poison
but i couldn't really make anything that
could even masquerade as food much worse
because there's not that many things
that are food
and they they split test optimize for
the most addictive ones and the
with the easiest palette ability with
that drives the most addiction it's like
maybe maybe they'll come out with a new
type of twinkie that's even more
addictive
but probably like they kind of already
did most of that search space right
um and they're making innovations like
okay can we make porn that is even more
addictive yeah vr
right so we'll do uh [ __ ] um
but so but the thing is like hypernormal
stimuli
that lead people to addictive behavior
is just good for capitalism
like if i run a business
i want to supply something people are
addicted to
be because the first rule of business if
i'm
you know i'm an mba the first rule is to
maximize lifetime revenue of a customer
and i maximize lifetime revenue very
well through addiction
and but what that means is that there
are lower and higher angels in my nature
and it's easier to make money off the
lower angels of my nature than the
higher ones
which means the money will go into
developing technologies
that will drive the lower angels
people's nature
which is why the underlying incentive
system is one of the things we have to
work on deeply
because whilst that's still in place
there's always going to be these
particular individual agents here and
there that will just
take advantage of other people deciding
to slow down
if you can't coordinate effectively
yeah i mean the reason to have rule of
law
is to bind the predatory aspects of
market incentive
um to say yes i know you can make money
by cutting down the national forest but
you know you're not allowed
and and we actually do
have a monopoly of violence with a
police force so if you try to take your
goons in there to say we're gonna do it
anyways we'll actually come physically
stop you
and yes you can make money killing
people and harvesting their organs and
selling them and no you're not allowed
to do that right like there's a bunch of
things that are just bad you shouldn't
do that
and so this is why we say no not just
total free-for-all free
market because um then what you end up
getting is a few people who have all the
money
like we have and most people have noma
the other people who
have most all of the money have
relatively unchecked power
in this kind of radical power asymmetry
to impose things that might totally suck
for the will of all these people so
these people say
we're going to pool our power into a
kind of labor union of sorts called the
state
and the state is going to take our
collective values that will encode as
rule of law
right our values as the basis of
jurisprudence
creating rule of law with a government
of people that are supposed to have no
vested interest at all because it's up
for and by the people
that are bequeathed with a monopoly of
violence so the state's even more
powerful than the top of the people in
the market more than the billionaires at
the top of the power law distribution
so that the values of the people can
check the otherwise radical asymmetries
of market differences
that's the idea right it obviously
breaks down because
what that means is those at the top of
the market have maximum incentive to
corrupt the state
to capture it to capture the regulators
and so
you see someone who works at the fda who
used to work at big ag or
um someone who works in the dod who used
to work at lockheed or whatever it is
you're like oh
that seems like an incentive problem um
and then you see that gdp goes up when
there's war
right and because we
spend a lot of money on military
manufacturing um
and
so the regulator that is supposed to
regulate the state ends up getting i
mean the
that is supposed to regulate the market
ends up getting captured by the market
because the state was supposed to be
regulated by the people
right a government formed by the people
with high transparency where the people
saw what was going on
so that the people so the
representatives were really representing
the will of the people not representing
their own private interests that were
being paid for by some kind of state
interest so
the state can only check the market in
so far as the people are checking the
state
the people obviously are not checking
the state at all the state is not trying
and nor are the market forces trying to
support the people to do that they're
trying to support the people to believe
that they can do that by voting every
four years or something
but having no real transparency insight
awareness
but um but yeah so the thing about
perverse incentive
well you have to be able to say
no that way that you can make money and
yes you'll be able to say hey they want
it
right i mean facebook is like we're just
providing a service people want right
and that's what the drug dealer says
when providing the drug to kids they're
paying for it right we're just providing
a service they want
yeah you there are weaknesses in people
that you can exploit and then they'll
want and you'll [ __ ] up their lives
we should not do that right that's not
like authentic voluntarism that's like
exploiting people's weaknesses and
talking up their life because of bad
incentives that's the thing we should
not do
we should provide goods and services
that enrich the quality of people's
lives and not provide the particularly
predatory ones
so that's where you need a state or you
need some kinds of forces to be able to
identify those and check them
we we and this is where we need better
collective sense making to be able to
identify oh these are perverse
incentives
oh we should actually make different
kinds of laws and regulations around
that oh
our whole process of law and regulation
is too slow for the rate that tech moves
how do we actually
change the structure of gov but our
governance system hasn't employed any of
the new tech
why is that china's government's
employing their the the new tech but for
an autocratic system we're not employing
it to make better open societies why not
taiwan's starting to we could it's
working there
um
yeah have you ever read seven eaves
by neil stephenson it's a hard sci-fi
book
so the moon explodes in the first
sentence
and the next two years are humanity
trying to
work out how they're going to survive
how they're going to get genetic progeny
somewhere right and they decide to go
through sort of a forked strategy they
send
some up to izzy the iss that then gets
made huge and loads of other stuff
happens
they send some under the water given the
fact that
you spend a lot of time thinking about
existential risk we don't have a second
community on mars or another planet or
anything
why haven't we created a siloed
community somewhere which is
like totally self-sufficient defended
air-gapped from the rest of the world
so that if anything was to happen
there is a contingency already in place
like that
well there kind of is in terms of do we
have deep underground military bases for
the continuity of governance
or government yes of course right like
especially
after world war ii and during the cold
war the idea if there's a nuclear attack
how do we have continuity of government
let's make
the bases do that and that they have the
um self-sustaining resource to be able
to do that
and then of course plenty of
billionaires have their own bug out
bunkers
for those scenarios why has the world
not created a its own
breakaway civilization
say something that the world has worked
together to do
at all like with with coordination
that isn't in the interests of those who
are working on it like
that's the deeper question there because
if if we could work together make a
breakaway civilization why not just make
this one much better
yeah yeah the global coordination does
seem to be the challenge you are right
it's just it's something that interested
me i'm reading this book i'm
looking at all of the challenges that
occur when you have an imminent threat
but as anyone that spent a bit of time
learning about existential risk the fact
that you can't see the imminence of
something doesn't mean that it isn't
imminent
like it could be it could be around the
[ __ ] corner
you know we didn't need much of a
difference in some of the parameters of
covid
to have made this a very imminent sort
of danger
and um rob i i suggested it to rob reed
last week and
he said um that he could think of a way
where this would almost be like
conscription in a way like you would do
your time
in the humanity 2.0 bunker
or whatever perhaps people would cycle
in and cycle out for a couple of years
at the time and it would be
something that would be really
prestigious and people would be picked
based on sort of
um genetic markers or or attributes that
they would want and we would always have
a siloed civilization just there ready
in case something was to happen to me
i'm aware that it's probably not going
to be super fun but also it kind of
might be fun there's not many things you
can do that not many other people have
done
um it seems like for any
country to do relatively small costs
yeah gonna suck for some people but it's
a pretty
small outlay for well
i mean university of
arizona biosphere 2 project was
something in that direction
right can we make a
closed uh sustaining
biosphere um
and it's hard and there's easier
versions that are not quite ambitious
that
all the big countries do have which is
uh
if the world blows up is there somebody
that still makes it well all
of the serious nuclear power submarines
are that
and they know that right when they go
when they go under
you could have full scale strategic
thermonuclear war on the surface and
they're still doing their thing
and they have the ability to do that
thing for a while and they have the
ability to
blow up a big portion of the world from
the
artillery they're carrying on them so
like the they're very interesting
like the the risk that they pose and the
psychological experiment
that nuclear equipped submarines are is
actually very interesting
um and so but that's also a continuity
of government military capacity thing
was okay well let's say
first strike happened all of a sudden
we've got these guys out there
and there's they they have the ability
to respond independent of whatever else
got blown up so
so that's like part partial experiments
like that have happened
i think this is how elon describes
part of his goal with mars is that we
can
take a stand somewhere else other than
earth asteroids and whatever
and as just a inspiring enough project
to motivate us to
to think positively about the future and
do something interesting
i'll tell you what i really like about
the mars colony
is and what i like about the idea that
you're saying even if it wasn't mars
colony but i think mars colony is maybe
the most popular version of it right now
and also a kind of well-resourced one
i like it as a thought experiment for
how to design civilization from scratch
because if i'm making a mars colony of
course there are some differences there
in here with like microgravity and
cosmic rays and microbiomes which are
pretty serious issues
but let's take those issues off and just
take
all the other ones that identical earth
would have
i still have this issue of how do i
make a civilization that does not
require import
and it doesn't mess itself up
uh there's going to be very limited
oxygen
i can't have the inefficiencies of a
bunch of
unnecessary farm animals breathing the
oxygen
if that's not a good way to produce
nutrient and caloric density
i can't have criminals who aren't
contributing anymore breathing the
oxygen
so how do i create a social system that
doesn't create criminals or that deals
with criminality in a way than putting
people in prisons for a long time
uh i can't just assume that we can get
new [ __ ] easily not only can i not
produce waste or trash i can't even
produce
micro pollution volatile organic
compounds from the epoxies or whatever
in this space and this very finite
amount of air supply
um i have to be able to make all of our
own hardware and software and mining and
everything
and all of our own biotech and if
anything breaks we have to be able to
make the tools to fix it all
right in the same space are we going to
use the same law that is retrofitting
stuff
back from like the 1200s or are we going
to redo law from scratch if so are we
going to do it on a blockchain what is
the basis
well if we're going to redo law what is
the jurisprudence upon which it's based
well what are the values upon which the
whole thing is based what is the
constitution what is the metaphysics
that gives rise to
how we pick the constitution if you
really want to think about a
mars colony you're thinking about
everything you think about the full tech
stack
the full suite of social technologies
how are we doing education and towards
what what is a developed human being
that we're trying to develop humans
towards
um and ultimately
what is the value system what is the
metaphysics that we are
that we're basing the constitution and
the educational theory and the
everything on as we get clear on that
because of that thought experiment then
it's well
could we rebuild the world here that way
could we build floating cities at sea
that where we don't have to produce our
own oxygen
and deal with all of our own co2 we can
still piggyback off this biosphere
um and we don't have the we just have to
ship it across the ocean not across the
solar system
you know for the import stuff that we do
need uh
could we do ground-up civilizations that
way um
and you know could some nation-states
pick up levels of
design iteration and even if we can't do
it ground up
knowing what it would look like can we
say now we know how to vector to make a
50-year plan to vector the current
system in that direction
that's something so the the actuality of
making it on mars actually
interests me less than the thought
experiment of
what the thing worth making would be and
then what it portends for us to get
clear on that
so the constraints of being somewhere
like mars where inefficiencies
whether they be metaphysical biological
technological
sociological legal all of these
show up potential flaws within the
system
and is it right to say that on earth
because the
the externalities of getting these
things wrong have sufficient slippage or
um they're opaque enough that we don't
actually get to see
when they happen we have it surplus
resources or at least we feel like we
have surplus resources
that can kind of chew up some of these
inefficiencies yet when you start to
bring those constraints in
in my super siloed
second world or whatever or on mars
that's when you actually get to see them
in a harsher light yeah it's not that
mars has
more constraints it has more and less
constraints in ways that
lead to more innovative design it has
more constraints in all the ways you
just mentioned it has less constraints
to be an iteration of the previous
things to stay bound to being
intelligible to the previous things
right it would be very hard to try to
make a really fundamentally different
law and culture in
in england because there's a very very
strong tradition there's very strong
basis of law what would be the
to it to bring it into being what would
the basis of law
in current law be to bring it into being
and does it even make that kind of thing
possible
whereas on the mars calling it's like we
got here first [ __ ] off we're doing it
right it's it's
more that kind of thing so whether they
get there or not even the thought
experiment of it is less constraints
about what it has to be or can be
based on our past and where the
constraints are more just
physics but those constraints are more
obvious to
us because we don't have the huge buffer
of pollutability and more resources
daniel schmuckenberger ladies and
gentlemen what can people expect from
you over the
the next few months where should people
go to check out interesting stuff that
you're doing at the moment
well the project that is still in just a
very very early beta phase but that has
most of my attention is
uh called the consilience project i'm
one of the
members of that team and so
consillianceproject.org
and it's really working on
right now uh through
a bunch of articles and then the
translation of those articles
through podcasts and then maybe
animation other forms of media
on helping people to understand
the problem space of the world better
the types of things we're talking about
the relationship between sense making
meaning making choice making
imposed order versus chaos and how do we
have emergent order
to understand some of the things well
enough to be able to start to think
about
the innovations that would actually make
a difference at a fundamental level how
do we understand the meta crisis well
enough
that we can design better we can imply
the more powerful exponential physical
technologies to make better social
technologies that are neither the
catastrophes or the dystopias
and how do we make both the need for
that and
the design criteria of what the
solutions would look like not exactly
the solutions but the design criteria of
the solutions to be able to kind of
drive it innovation zeitgeist so both
existing institutions can say
wow we need to reform ourselves and we
need to reform ourselves in these ways
and
new independent groups like blockchain
governance imperatives and whatever can
can also innovate informed by
uh these things so that's that's um
where
much of the attention is and then every
once in a while i get uh
invited like by yourself to do a podcast
on interesting and fun and random topics
and
so i have a blog that is basically just
a place i put podcasts called
civilizationemerging.com people can
check that out
awesome that'll be linked in the show
notes below daniel it's always a
pleasure thank you so much
thank you my friend thank you for having
me it's good to be back with you
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace
you